[Music]
in when kids attack news their bastard
submitted by fo for me okay so I will
always say kids are lucky their kill for
me they would have been [ __ ] up a long
time ago an adult male and a group of
children were filmed confronting a
hunter for killing a deer of course the
children coming in like thank you if I
could switch plate night do we know you
want to [ __ ] a Bambi ha ha ha you know
Mom you know all right so this you want
to [ __ ] up one of ours
this happened in Long Island Long Island
and guy's name is Dominick he's from
Brooklyn nailed it that was actually I
could and so he ended up visiting Queen
Queen queen he was on his way to the
Bronx Bronx because he's making the same
[ __ ] voices every time no we're not
you listen it's just the untrained ear
doesn't [ __ ] pick up on it you know
the boss isn't listing all these things
and then like somehow he ended up in a
briefs I know how to in the
in Hell's Kitchen oh hell no here's a
real story so his name is Dominic he is
from Brooklyn he recorded this on his
cell phone
and so he showed up to this area that
where he had already previously called
Dec which is New York's Department of
Environmental Conservation to make sure
that the area he was going into was
legal for him to hunt deer so when he
got out of his car he was wearing camo
and that's when this man and his group
of children start surrounding him why is
this man with so many children that's
the real feliza Scoutmaster deal when he
gets confronted like this is he getting
loaded uh no cuz he can still talk oh I
see okay I'm trying to but it is just
when you're just when they shut you up
got ya and it got you it's a good
cutting back or something like you
usually because it's it's like they were
they've been embarrassed because this
guy thought he was like he was right and
he was wrong that's when you get back
it's motive oh oh you think you're ever
like I swear this little button oh no no
no no no no no and then you finally pull
up evidence people in your face issues
oh dude oh that's motive okay cool what
happens very rarely but uh I have like
that you've been thinking about this for
like a video a video okay soul time
figured out 90s children thing to say
got it
I know I wonder what the kids these days
they know I don't know but let's bring
your guys like a [ __ ] mom if I ever
never say that's Lynn I'm always gonna
say it's dope no one says that slit
anymore it's say that like Lydia or God
oh [ __ ] it well Timmy says fire all the
time he says a regular fire that's old
us fire fire breath but I have to say of
all the people who say fire regularly I
like the way that he does it the best
and I like the way that dumbfounded
doesn't the least okay here we go
here's the video I mean cuz timpz is
appropriately yeah I think so
because I eat them why because I eat
them I eat them you redo it buy meat
from the supermarket yeah you know they
get killed they get killed even they
can't kills in dirty areas nasty a whole
bunch of blood leaking that's why I'm
saying you don't want that you're like
you're like a hero on Long Island right
now
that's because kids are upset they're
crying because you want to kill D that
crying you look like some bleeding
around that it's my life yeah why don't
you go get away
excuse me please don't hit my car yep
good the person somebody's not trying to
do anything bad okay and I'm gonna eat
it instead you let somebody else kill it
the guy is coming here on the way now
the officer is on the way
there's another guy they killed in dirty
areas nasty a whole bunch of blood
leaking that's why I'm saying that's why
you don't want that you're like you're
like a hero they crying because you want
to kill deer I'm sorry that they're
crying you need to another video playing
oh you might open it twice
cuz you possible I was getting loaded
right now in modern itself that was
trippy it happened like halfway
from the other article oh I'll strip it
out I was like it took forever to load
it okay let's bring it back a little I
can few movie where it lets weren't
moving but over here I don't remember
recording twice why's he look like Porky
Pig so he gets to go to the burger store
and kill animals that were slaughtered
in [ __ ] nuts ways and this guy kills
a deer in the way that they killed deer
is to [ __ ] kill them instantly
that's what's considered a good clean
kill the free life the funny thing is
they treat him like he's some animal
when these guys are acting like the
lowlife animals yeah it's like that's
when [ __ ] morons think that they're
more intelligent than the rest of the
world this is what happens I mean if
you're siding with the kid that's
already not a good look
kids got bad arguments - he's like you
these animals are killing crazy dirty
ways and he's like well this is not a
dirty way uh listen to the kid he's got
a good nose watch it to me so listen why
don't you go to the grocery store buy me
what what they can't even make the
connection that blue is mine that was
like oh he's like I have to now I have
to explain my kid why you killed a deer
today it's those people like if he was
in a non hunting area I I'm on the kids
side if he didn't have a license he's
waiting for a deficient wildlife the
game warden to come down to validate hey
I have permission to hunt here so he's
not breaking the law he's doing
everything that he's supposed to and
these fools I think they're so dumb they
don't understand the lot of trying to
kick him out yeah so then they're saying
that the dad the guy with the yellow
shirt he ended up calling the police
accusing him the guy of having an issue
while asking him to simply go away and
then that's when the cops show up or
they the Department of Environmental
Conservation and an officer showed up
they both confirmed that Dominick was
there 100% legally and he had all the
necessary permits so there was nothing
like it's funny when people come up to
people very
and then call the cops on them it's
funny too because they're like well I
find this wrong for surely the police
will agree with me and then the police
is like no we do not agree no your card
kidding me the system's broken yeah yeah
I'm so glad I don't have any neighbors
like that look see this is Mike but you
don't know this is the main reason why I
want more and more money more money so
you don't have neighbors like this
this is this is obviously trash behavior
it's idiot trash behavior right and even
if your neighbor was idiot trash but
just rich you have miles and miles of
[ __ ] space in between you and them
and they don't enrich people don't
[ __ ] play outside they play in their
own [ __ ] basketball court in the
backyard how is the comments on this
stuff are these is this family getting
loaded right now because of what's going
on hmm
what I'm scared of is that there might
be some of the public that's so stupid
that they're actually on the kid and the
dad side because they don't understand
the laws that's kind of disappointing
part yeah money insulates you from
[ __ ] stupidity you could run away far
and far away because if it was up to me
you might first I thought I just stopped
myself from okay I'll say it
thank you do you even know what you're
gonna say yeah he's trying to word it in
a way where he doesn't have to make an
apology I'll just kill him all oh you
killed who you killing everyone that
annoys me yeah Wow yeah I mean you've
said that before yeah you said that many
times
but specifically I was thinking about
ways that have been used before like
rounding up people that I don't like and
then putting them in I was like ah
that's a great yeah it was a great idea
but should I say it right now [ __ ] I
said it anyway [ __ ] yep so the
man five years you're buying it to pay
around good for you guys that's right
yeah you hear that stuff well yeah so
the people that are
the comments of the original video they
seem to be really appalled at this does
dad's bad parenting yes and his kids
like obviously like he's got anger
issues man major anger issues
[ __ ] your own mother he's taking it
as if this guy who is legally hunting
and grounds have been set for hunting by
the state as if someone's gonna shoot
his dog yeah he's following the law and
it's like you're gonna kill my golden
retriever why is it legal to get out of
that car spank the [ __ ] out of the kid
[ __ ] up the dad and make them make him
be a good parent salt on the kids
assaulting on the gun on an adult why is
that illegal though I don't understand
because no one wants to get their ass
kicked
oh I would I would let him do it in that
situation I think he could he could have
walked out beat the [ __ ] out of that kid
because that kid doesn't know how to
speak to adults beat the [ __ ] out of the
dude because he looks like Porky Pig and
beat the [ __ ] out of the little kid
behind him cuz he looks like baby Porky
Pig [ __ ] out of everybody yeah I wish
there was a permit that you could buy
the beat kids and adults
I would renew my permit over you I'll be
cool if you're loud like sorry I gotta
beat your ass like a punch card yeah
yeah you got a license to beat ass right
it's a punch everyone's like everyone
has like a [ __ ] punch card thing
right so after you get your ass beat yo
can I see your punch card
alright you used it you're only allowed
for ten every year that's the same thing
as like Environmental Conservation where
they allow a limited amount of like I
don't hear yep but then if you if you go
over the limit ass kickings if you go
over the limit you get fined big time
yeah like hundred thousand dollars you
know what I would honestly do is take
that kid home opposed the dad and my kid
was being this way I would take that get
home and I would show him a [ __ ]
slaughterhouse video and be like that's
what you ate for dinner last night
that's your chicken nuggets
we're good pay Thank You Jenna dad's too
stupid ease watch the video first well
right that's what I'm saying but if my
kid reacted that way I would try to
research it so that I could teach my
kids something yeah I may be myself
[Music]